ils sont des cantons de château où ils
sartrouville et saint germain en laye et
présentent ensemble leur candidature
pour les élections départementales de
juin prochain
quatre binômes de la majorité de la
communauté d'agglomération saint germain
boucles de seine on travaille au
quotidien à travers l'agglomération sur
le déclarant sujet qui compte pour nos
habitants réciproque et en même temps
finalement le socle le l'acteur
départementale déjà de façon naturelle
compléter cette palette de partenaires
et de d'institutions et de collectivités
qui viennent travailler ensemble au
service des projets de territoires qui
sont essentiels pour nos habitants
pas d'étiquette politique mais leur
candidature s'inscrit dans la majorité
départementale
l'objectif de ces élus compléter la
force de leur commune avec celle du
département
le département et avec la région comme
on l'a rappelé le premier où l'un des
premiers partenaires financiers des
communes et que nous avons été élus les
uns et les autres dans nos communes
respectives
il y un peu plus d'un an sur la base
d'un progrès que si nous voulons
réaliser ce projet il nous faut aussi le
partenariat l'aide les financements du
département bien sûr et de la région ils
veulent donc faire du département un
partenaire privilégié pour soutenir les
projets locaux
l'enjeu préserver le cadre de vie du
territoire
mon coeur bat pour à tout ce qui est
patrimoine culturel et naturel et je
sais combien c'est important dans nos
communes et au sein du département des
yvelines
je voudrais apporter ma pierre à
l'édifice et contribué à mettre en place
de nouveaux projets on mettre en valeur
ce patrimoine pour le préserver le but
est aussi de défendre des idées qui ont
un impact sur le quotidien des
administrés par exemple d'ailleurs les
politiques que nous mettons en oeuvre au
niveau des seniors
c'est une compétence importante du
département et dans cette
c'est un enjeu majeur beaucoup d pad
mais on pourrait parler beaucoup plus du
maintien à domicile et deux aménagements
qui doivent être mises en place pour
favoriser le maintien à domicile les
politiques donc au tour des seniors mais
aussi de la jeunesse et les candidats
revendiquent un projet autour de la
solidarité d'un projet solidaire c'est
un projet environnemental savent où j'ai
tourné vers l'avenir et c'est en même
temps auger respectueux du diable dans
lequel nous vivons nous ont légué les
générations précédentes
actuellement la droite dispose de la
totalité des sièges au sein du
département les élus espèrent réaliser
un nouveau grand chelem